[Music]
gotcha the devil let me out of here I I
demand to be released incredible I can
speak well of course I can speak now let
me out of here or I shall shriek let me
out not until I take a good look at
you good evening so you're the funny
little man who's been F me funny little
now how dare you I will have you know
that I am a perfectly respectable size
for an OA Lumpa an OA what now in fact
in Lumpa land I am regarded as something
of a Whopper they call me lofty so I
will thank you to stop gping at me as
though I was something unpleasant you'd
found in your handkerchief I find it
uncomfortable and frankly
rude sorry now let me out of here you
have absolutely no right to go around
EMB bottling innocent strangers innocent
hold on you've been stealing from me for
years well you've started it me you
stole our cocoa beans what are you
talking
about do you mean that you don't even
remember remember what the day
you destroyed my life no I don't
remember that well then young man allow
me to refresh your memory in the form of
a song so ruinously catchy that it may
never leave your
mind oh I don't think I want to hear
that too late I started dancing now once
we've started we can't
[Music]
stop I've got a tragic tale for you
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little now
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for an
OA Luma Ana what now in fact in Lumpa
land I am regarded as something of a
Whopper they call me lofty sorry
ladies and gentlemen greetings to you
all my name is Willie won you see I'm
something of a magician prepare to be
amazed a tap
up inventor may I present Willy Walker's
wild and wonderful wishy washy WKA
Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world
ooh he's good too good and anyone can
for them even the the poor he doesn't
like it when people say poor send Wonka
a message do not sell chocolate in this
town you're going to get more than a
bonk on the head I love a bonk on the
head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
bullies give them the old one
too I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of
course
run away every good thing in this world
started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world
I'm not in premium e good night sir I am
going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well huh you did it again tell me what
it is or I shall poke quite viciously
with a cocktail
[Music]
stick